SUBJECT 1: The
dictionary defines love
as a feeling of strong
or constant affection
for a person.
In the real world,
though, we can all
agree that love is way more
complex and nuanced than that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 2: Love is
caring to other.
SUBJECT 3: Caring about
someone else's existence.
SUBJECT 4: Is the most
beautiful word in the world.
SUBJECT 1: These folks
were just a small fraction
of hundreds who took part
in the Love IS project,
started by socially conscious
designer, Chrissie Lam.
CHRISSIE LAM: The Love Is
project combines social impact
product, while connecting
people around the world,
through storytelling.
The focus-- for universal
meaning of the word, love.
It aims to put the meaning
behind the message.
These are real people
and their stories.
SUBJECT 1: But the
Love Is project
is more than just a collection
of thoughts on love.
At its heart is a
simple red bracelet,
emblazoned with the
universal message--
SUBJECT 5: Love is Happiness.
Happiness is Love.
SUBJECT 1: Chrissie's design
firm works with Maasai women,
enabling them to sell
traditional, autimsal crafts
around the world.
CHRISSIE LAM: I worked
with Maasai mums
in Kenya's Great Rift Valley
to design new products.
Finding myself inspired by the
vibrant colors and patterns
of the tribe, we
developed an idea
to design a simple, bold,
and scalable message bracelet
in their traditional beading.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: The Love bracelet
empowers these women
by providing them with
a sustainable income.
After the first
bracelets were made,
Chrissie was looking for ways
to highlight the project,
and it was on her travels
that inspiration struck.
CHRISSIE LAM: Just
over a year later,
with the Love bracelet in
hand, on a flight to Russia,
I struck up a conversation
with two perfect strangers.
Girls from East
Pakistan and Kogistan.
On a whim, I asked
them about love.
Upon landing at Moscow airport,
inspired by their answers,
I snapped and uploaded a
photo of them wearing the love
bracelet to Instagram.
The Love Is project had begun.
SUBJECT 1: Since then,
the Love Is project
has asked over 500 people,
representing 19 nationalities,
what they think love is.
And I've documented them all
wearing the Maasai bracelets.
SUBJECT 6: Love is
healthy and happy.
SUBJECT 7: Family and friends.
SUBJECT 8: It's infinite.
SUBJECT 9: Love is my family.
SUBJECT 10: A gift.
SUBJECT 11: It's
all encompassing.
SUBJECT 12: Love.
SUBJECT 1: And after asking
all those people what love is,
Chrissie can definitely
vouch for the idea
that everyone's perspective
on the subject is unique.
CHRISSIE LAM: Answers vary
depending on the country,
region you're visiting, as well
as the social, economic class,
and religion.
I think love is a broad concept.
It's open ended.
It can be hard to define,
because it encompasses so much.
SUBJECT 1: Today, the project
continues to inspire and unite
people around the world.
Its message of love
and empowerment
has touched many people.
But most of all, the
Maasai women in Kenya.
CHRISSIE LAM: It's
astounding to see
how big our love has
grown in a short time
span around the globe.
It's equally extraordinary to
witness the impact of the Love
Is project on lives and
communities in Kenya.
SUBJECT 1: Sometimes love
means making a grand gesture.
Kay Jewelers has the perfect
gift for your loved one.
Kay Jewelers-- every
kiss begins with k.
SUBJECT 13: Empowering
messages can be found
in the most unlikely places.
Click to watch an episode
on why this flight attendant
rights inspirational
notes on airplane windows.
SUBJECT 14: You're
already invited.
It was, just like, a pick-me-up.
Like, you're already invited
to, like, kill this day.
To, like, nail it, to
have the best day ever.
Like, it's already
set up for you.
You just have to,
like, go do it.
So that was the encouragement
behind that specific works
from the window seat.
SUBJECT 15: Thanks for
watching, and don't
forget to subscribe
to see the stories.